notre invité politique ce matin sénat
john vallaud belkacem bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes
candidate aux régionales dans la région
auvergne rhône-alpes à la tête de la
liste l'alternative pour résumer pour
simplifier c'est une liste qui regroupe
le parti socialiste le prg quelques
écologistes quelques communistes et
d'autres forces de gauche c'est ça une
fête avec nous pendant 20 minutes plus
tard au partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
pascal fouda même le groupe ebra bonjour
pascal les journaux régionaux de
l'auvergne rhône-alpes notamment et de
l'est de la france on commence avant de
parler des régionales nadia de la
nouvelle kacem par l'actualité et en
hommage qui a été rendu hier soir à
cette fonctionnaire de police qui a été
assassiné vendredi dans son commissariat
de rambouillet demain gérald darmanin va
présenter une loi en conseil des
ministres pour renforcer la prévention
des actes de terrorisme
pour renforcer le renseignement est ce
qu'il fallait de nouvelles mesures moi
je pense que vraiment ces sujets dans la
mesure du possible doivent appeler le
consensus je sais que beaucoup de forces
politiques sont toujours tentés bain de
d'en tirer parti d'une certaine façon
pour se lancer dans des concours lépine
moi je pense vraiment que il faut un
débat serein il y a des lois qui
existent elles ont indéniablement besoin
d'être renforcée sur certains aspects il
faut faire attention en effet à ce que
les libertés publiques ne soit pas
balayée du revers de la main
mais si il s'agit par exemple en effet
de renforcer la dimension renseignements
détection suivi des radicaliser et
notamment en prison parce que c'est vrai
que c'est quelque chose on s'en est
rendu compte 1 quand on a été aux
responsabilités qui avaient complètement
été occulté par le passé et donc il faut
il mettre toujours plus de moyens
faisons le on avait commencé à le faire
il faut le poursuivre si c'est des
dispositions visant à assurer un suivi y
compris après la sortie de prison un
suivi administratif
sous le contrôle du juge ça me paraît en
effet pertinents
mais les libertés publiques je le redis
ici doivent quand même constitué à
chaque fois une garde fous pourquoi
parce que ce que cherche justement à
fracturer les terroristes c'est notre
capacité à vivre avec cette cette
qualité de vie qui est la nôtre parce
que nous sommes protégés y compris par
des libertés publiques
donc ne leur donnons des pare-brises les
mesures qu'on connaît de ce texte
présenté demain sont les bonnes y
compris une surveillance renforcée des
réseaux sociaux des outils numériques
oui je pense vraiment que aujourd'hui il
faut il faut trouver une forme de
consensus sur ce dont on a besoin pour
se sentir davantage en sécurité dans un
pays où malheureusement les actes
terroristes sont devenus très nombreux
et surtout où on voit qu'ils ont été
capables y compris de d'entrer dans un
commissariat qui a priori est quand même
le sanctuaire de la sécurité si on ne se
sent pas en sécurité dans un
commissariat où peut-on se sentir en
sécurité
le terroriste était arrivé en france en
2009 de manière clandestine il est resté
de manière clandestine en france pendant
dix ans la droite relance le débat sur
le lien entre terrorisme et
l'immigration est ce que pour vous il ya
un lien c'est ça que j'appelle le
concours lépine de la réaction et voilà
et de l'interprétation
le problème si vous voulez c'est que
quand vous regardez la nature des
terroristes des ces derniers
onze années et triste épisode il y en a
dans mon souvenir davantage qu'ils
étaient des citoyens français que ceux
qui étaient des citoyens étrangers donc
les assimilations trop rapide les
interprétations aux fonds qui vise
finalement une fois de plus elle aussi à
fracturer la société ne sont pas
bienvenus en la matière je pense
vraiment qu'aujourd'hui si on veut
traiter sérieusement le sujet du
terrorisme
c'est à la fois de sécurité dont il est
question et je viens de dire notamment
sur la dimension renseignements il faut
nous renforcer indéniablement mais c'est
aussi sur le message qui est envoyé
finalement à notre société est passé son
temps à assimiler des populations qui
n'ont rien demandé
qui qui se sont intégrés qui
non jamais ni soutenu ni commis le
moindre acte alors elle est présentée
comme des potentiels complices des
terroristes ça n'est pas assuré une
capacité de visa il ne faut pas poser la
question notre politique migratoire
qu'il ne faut pas par exemple renforcer
le contrôle de nos frontières comme le
pense une partie de la droite mais il
faut renforcer tous les contrôles
possibles c'est évidemment pertinent
puisque on voit bien qu'il ya en effet
par le passé on a vu des terroristes
s'immiscer dans des files de personnes
qui venaient sur les territoires donc et
bien sûr qu'il faut renforcer le
contrôle et renforcer la sécurité
mais il ne faut pas comment dire faire
de petits calculs électoraux sur des
situations aussi grave aussi
désespérante est aussi franchement plein
de ce fait la joie de peine que c'est à
l'électorat que celle de rambouillet je
pense qu'il ya malheureusement dans
cette course à l'échalote de qui
proposera la mesure la plus sécuritaire
ou l'interprétation et la simulation
l'amalgamme le plus important une espèce
oui de course à l'échalote et de
concours lépine qui ne convient pas la
situation on a besoin de sérieux
pascal oui toujours dans le registre
cette fois sécuritaire on a vu alors à
vaulx en velin à lyon à tourcoing les ce
qu'on appelle les banlieues les cités
sont très agités
il y avait intention social sécuritaire
et surtout l'absence de services publics
que vont-ils faire pour apaiser on en a
eu en effet plusieurs exemples y compris
dans notre région ce qu'il faut faire
pour apaiser
enfin si vous voulez si le sujet c'est
celui de ces jeunes puisque c'est il
s'agit souvent de bande
voilà deux jeunes il ya beaucoup de
sujets il ya à la fois
en effet la fermeté à l'égard d'un
certain nombre de comportements qui
relève de l'incivilité au départ et qui
parce qu'ils ne sont pas suffisamment
arrêté va se transformer en délinquant
c'est plus mais il y à aussi au fond ces
jeunes qu'est-ce qu'on leur offre comme
perspective on a aujourd'hui un vrai
problème dans ce pays et qui ne va faire
que s'accroître un je le dis ici c'est
évidemment la question du chômage
la question de la pauvreté la question
du manque de formation pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux est donc en l'absence
de toutes ces perspectives finalement à
part se diriger vers des activités
illégales
qu'est ce que la société leur donne à
voir et je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'il
manque dans ce pays c'est une grande
mobilisation pour la jeunesse une grande
mobilisation alors il ya eu plein de
débat autour de ce qu'il faut un rsa
jeunes etc
peu importe la forme qu'elle prenne il
faut une grande mobilisation pour faire
en sorte que chacun parmi nos jeunes
trouvent finalement à la fois un horizon
un espoir dans cette période de crise
sanitaire c'est quand même
particulièrement compliqué pour eux et
surtout un cadre un cadre une forme de
mentorat
je fais le tour en ce moment de beaucoup
de villes ou
des zones rurales de la région auvergne
rhône-alpes et je peux vous dire que
souvent me revient cette idée que ce qui
nous manque me disent ils c'est
quelqu'un pour nous guider quelqu'un
pour nous dire ce qui existe ce qu'il
est possible de faire et je trouve qu'en
fait aujourd'hui c'est ça dont souffrent
beaucoup la jeunesse et qu'elle doit
être accompagnée que les collectivités
locales en particulier parce qu'elles
sont dans la proximité ont un rôle
particulier à jouer les communes les
départements les conseils régionaux
évidemment mais qu'on peut pas
simplement déploré un mauvais
comportement qu'il faut s'intéresser
aussi aux racines
l'autre actualité c'est évidemment la
crise sanitaire et hier la réouverture
des écoles primaires et maternelles vous
l'ancien ministre l'éducation nationale
est ce que vous dites
le gouvernement a eu raison de rouvrir
les écoles malgré les chiffres toujours
élevé de l'épidémie on est tous d'accord
qu il vaut mieux des écoles ouvertes que
des écoles fermées trop longtemps je n'y
reviens pas mais la question c'est
quelles sont les conditions de cette
réouverture
moi ce qui me frappe c'est de voir au
fond le manque de préparation l'absence
d'anticipation du gouvernement sur ce
sujet parce que quand vous voyez
cueillir encore les réseaux internet etc
enfin le lait les réseaux qui permettent
les cours à distance
voilà exactement tout ce qui permet
l'enseignement à distance et notamment
le cned voilà je cherchais eh bien ça a
buggé une fois de plus on se dit mais
enfin c'est pas comme si on était en
mars 2020 on est quand même plus d'un an
après on a eu le temps normalement de
préparer tout cela donc il ya un manque
d'anticipation qui vient de quoi qui
vient au fond d'un aveuglement à la
réalité des problématiques dans les
écoles longtemps le ministre de
l'éducation a signé le fait même que le
virus pouvait circuler parmi les élèves
dans les écoles
nier que potentiellement les écoles
pouvaient devenir des clusters jusqu'à
ce qu'on aperçoit abrite l'école c'est
ni plus ni moins contaminateur un autre
endroit est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ça jusqu'à ce qu'on s'aperçoive
il ya deux mois et demi que lycées de
seine-saint-denis avait depuis un an une
vingt parents d'élèves qui étaient
décédés du cobp ide et qu'on avait en
fait toujours pas réagi je trouve ça
mais c'est pardonné - l'émotion me
montrent vraiment aux yeux quand je
prends connaissance d'une telle
information ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
tout ça va le diront que ce n'est pas le
bon dans les primaires dans les
matériels de dire que depuis le début de
cette histoire dans les établissements
scolaires rien n'est anticipée rien et
anticiper sa vraisemblable
on n'a absolument pas travaillé
suffisamment les protocoles sanitaires
je vais pas vous dire à quel point les
cantines scolaires sont des clusters et
et honnêtement je ne comprends toujours
pas pourquoi on ne travaille pas
davantage avec les collectivités locales
notamment pour désengorger justement
pour avoir plus de lieux qui fasse
office de cantine scolaire par exemple
on n'a absolument pas vacciner les
enseignants annoncent qu'il fallait
faire mais où vit mais évidemment qu'il
fallait vacciner les enseignants on a
arrêté les écoles et les collèges et les
lycées pendant quatre semaines
grosso modo enfin quelques ajustements
près avec les vacances pendant ce temps
là on aurait pu se donner comme priorité
de vacciner tous les personnels
enseignants qu'ils allaient se retrouver
ensuite face à leurs élèves pour qu'on
ne l'a pas fait c'est vraiment c'est une
question de priorité et de cap qu'on se
fixe et de la même façon est ce qu'un
travail a été fait pour la question de
l'aération dans les salles de classe des
purificateurs brothers alors embaucher
il a été en pointe pour le coup sur
cette question la région verdun alpes a
investi 10 millions pour équiper les
établissements scolaires depuis rifle et
14 heures est ce que vous dites là il a
eu raison il a bien fait oui je pense
qu'il a bien fait oui je ne suis pas
sectaire je pense que sur les
purificateurs d'air il a bien fait mais
je peux quand même si vous voulez il
s'est retrouvé exactement dans la même
situation que d'autres collectivités
locales qui ont dû pallier les
insuffisances de l'état par exemple je
pense au moment du premier confinement
lorsque on s'est rendu compte que ben
comme les enfants n'étaient plus à
l'école certains d'entre eux ne mangeait
tout simplement plus à leur faim il a
fallu que ce soit les mairies certaines
mairies
c'est le seul problème c'est que du coup
c'est pas pareil partout sur le
territoire
certaines mairies comme celle de
il comme celle de paris qui s'en rendent
compte et qui décide de livrer des
paniers repas aux familles les plus
pauvres pour que leurs enfants mangent
comme s'ils étaient à la cantine ou des
bons donc si vous voulez moi ce que je
reproche au gouvernement c'est qu'on a
l'impression que lui est toujours
aveugle et sourd aux difficultés et
notamment à celles qui relèvent de la
vulnérabilité de la précarité de
fragilité et qu'il faut que ce soit
d'autres collectivités qui viennent les
pallier ces insuffisances m'expliquer ça
de la part du gouvernement
je pense vraiment que ça n'est pas dans
son logiciel en fait vraiment jeu il a
fallu quand même très longtemps avant
qu'il se rende compte que des gens et
notamment des jeunes faisait la queue
devant l'aide alimentaire et que c'était
plus possible il a fallu vraiment très
longtemps pour qu'ils s'en rendent
compte que des quartiers populaires
j'évoquais la seine saint denis tout à
l'heure et ben oui compte tenu des
conditions de promiscuité et c'est dans
lesquelles vivent ces habitants et est
tombé dans une fragilité bien plus
grande encore que le reste du pays qu'il
fallait s'en occuper je pense que la
pauvreté la grande pauvreté la précarité
n'est pas son son coeur de métier j'ai
envie de dire son centre d'intérêt
principal et preuve en est que ce
gouvernement arrive quand même à faire
passer une réforme de l'assurance
chômage qui va précariser les plus
fragiles il faut le savoir
en plein milieu d'une crise économique
absolument majeure comme celle qu'on
traverse la donc moi je vous revenir à
l'école
si vous voulez je ne me sens pas
particulièrement sécurisé ni comme
parent d'élève parce qu'en fait on se
dit mais alors du coup si jamais un par
un à un
un professeur est infecté par le cos
vide est ce qu'on a prévu des
remplaçants si l'important c'est de
retourner à l'école c'est cette
continuité pédagogique
mais vous vous êtes un fan de mettre vos
enfants à l'école en ce moment moi je
vais les remettre mais le sujet c'est
pas ça c'est que si vous voulez on a le
sentiment qu'on nous vend l'histoire
d'une école qu'il vaut mieux ouverte que
fermer mais lorsque le dysfonctionnement
pour advient parce que par exemple d'un
professeur et soudain affecté au co vide
est-ce qu'on a rempli prévu des
remplaçants la réponse est non enfin je
veux dire vous en avez conscience il n'y
a pas de remplaçants prévu on va parler
des conséquences de la crise nous irons
qu'on arrive dans la région voilà donc
on arrivait au déconfinement faut-il
appliquer la même règle partout alors
mais dans un département comme le cantal
allier où ça circule le plus d confiné
plus vite par département par région co
comment voyez vous cela et qu'est ce
qu'on vit dans les territoires alors il
y est venu tardivement le président la
république mais mais on peut saluer le
fait qu'ils y viennent enfin je pense en
effet que une gestion territorialisée
une gestion adaptée à la réalité de la
circulation du virus est mieux adapté
qu'une gestion trop centralisée
d'ailleurs depuis le début je pense que
ce qui a péché c'est vraiment cette trop
grande centralisation qui a empêché de
trouver des solutions
enfin qu'on trouve au niveau local je
vous en donne un exemple
par exemple les étudiants que à
l'automne dernier on a fait arrêter
brutalement leurs cours en disant mais
oh là là les amphithéâtres des
universités sont devenues autant de
clusters à l'échelle territoriale je
vous assure que dans un travail en
collaboration avec les collectivités
locales
on pouvait trouver des lieux des lieux
associatifs des sièges d'entreprises qui
met utilisait plus et c'est pour
répartir ces étudiants en petites
grappes en petit groupe
mais leur permette de continuer à
étudier finalement et à faire du lien
social plutôt que d'être enfermé dans
des chambres étudiantes de 9 m kg
il faut des confiné à quelle échelle
pour vous par département par région le
gouvernement n'a pas précisé je pense
qu'à l'échelle des départements ça me
paraît pertinent mais bonne ça je pense
que c'est vraiment sur la base de
projections très fiable qu'il faut le
dessin auvergne et rhône-alpes la crise
sanitaire a eu des conséquences
économiques assez particulière on pense
notamment ou à toute l'activité montagne
de l'hiver ou pour beaucoup de salariés
c'est très important
comment gérez vous ces difficultés si
vous étiez aux commandes de la région
c'est ça c'est ça fait partie des
premiers acteurs avec lesquels je me
suis entretenu les acteurs de la
montagne parce que en fait eu comme
d'ailleurs les acteurs de l'agriculture
sont particulièrement impacté par le
changement climatique
on a beaucoup parlé des acteurs de
l'agriculture récemment parce qu'on
évoquait le gel et ses dégâts mais les
acteurs de la montagne aussi quand on
voit en effet que sur les 50 dernières
années
c'est un mois d'enneigement sur l'année
qui a été perdu compte tenu du
réchauffement climatique donc on voit
bien que le modèle des sports d'hiver
peut pas suffire malheureusement à faire
tourner une économie de montagne et
qu'il faut quand même diversifier les
activités et donc je pense qu'une région
en fait c'est c'est ça qu'elle doit
faire
une collectivité régionale elle est chef
de file sur ces questions là parce
qu'elle est en charge de l'aménagement
du territoire et du développement
économique qui plus est donc du coup
elle doit préparer la suite et en fait
moi ce que je reproche au président de
la région sortant laurent wauquiez qui a
pourtant beaucoup communiqué sur son
rapport avec la montagne et les acteurs
de la montagne c'est qu'en fait il n'a
en rien préparer la suite en quoi est ce
que il a investi pour diversifier les
activités pour qu'on fasse du vtt pour
qu'on fasse et de multi du bien-être du
thermalisme et c'est en montagne en quoi
est ce qu'il a investi dans des
infrastructures dont la montagne a
besoin je pense par exemple aux
ascenseurs valait 1 qui permettent
d'éviter qu'on monte avec sa voiture
tout en haut et qu'on pollue l'espace et
c'est donc moi ce que je propose sur ce
sujet bien précis c'est qu'on mette tous
les acteurs autour de la table et que
on dégage un budget de 2 milliards
d'euros sur l'ensemble du mandat qu on
consacrera à reconstruire au fond
l'avenir de la montagne avec les acteurs
un mot sur l'écologie vous allez
présenter votre programme la semaine
prochaine je crois dans le messie on
une liste que vous avez déjà présenté la
transition écologique ça fait quand même
partie de vos priorités je crois que
vous voulez un parlement climatiques
régionales
en quoi ça consiste en fait je suis
frappé de voir à quel point l'écologie
et la nécessaire transition écologique
donc pour ma part je suis absolument
convaincu est encore un sujet qui pour
certains ne fait pas sens est source de
confusion
qu'est ce qu'on va nous empêcher de
faire en quoi c'est une atteinte à nos
libertés etc
en fait la transition écologique si on
veut qu'elle marche il faut que le
maximum de gens se l'approprient la
comprennent or j'ai remarqué une chose
parce que j'ai eu l'occasion justement
de faire ces quatre ans de pause et de
beaucoup travaillé sur la façon dont les
opinions s'approprient les sujets c'est
que rien de tel que une pédagogie une
communication régulière sur les sujets
qui nous paraissent essentiels si le
changement climatique à l'oeuvre est si
grave
comme je viens de l'évoquer avec par
exemple la montagne ou l'agriculture
aujourd'hui les acteurs de la montagne
et de l'agriculture le savent parce
qu'il le voit au quotidien
est ce que quelqu'un qui vit dans un
quartier populaire de l'agglomération
lyonnaise par exemple on a conscience à
ce point pas forcément et c'est là où le
parlement c'est quoi c'est une sorte de
convention citoyenne non plus qu'une
convention enfin oui c'est une
convention citoyenne permanente voilà le
mot permanente importe le parlement
climatiques régionales c'est un lieu
d'information et c'est un lieu de
décision
un lieu d'information où se rassemble à
la fois des experts donc de la question
de la transition écologique mais aussi
des scientifiques en sociologie en
histoire en philosophie pour nous aider
à comprendre ce qui nous arrive des
associations des citoyens tirés au sort
qu'on met ensemble sur la durée du
mandat et à qui on demande à la fois et
bien de faire partager à tous les
habitants de l'auvergne et rhône alpes
sous forme de conférence de presse
hebdomadaire
les avancées du changement climatique
sur notre territoire pour que justement
il est cette information voilà concrètes
pour tout le monde et à qui on demande
en même temps de juger des politiques
régionales pour veiller à ce qu'elles
aillent dans le bon sens de la
transition écologique c'est-à-dire les
juges a posteriori bas et politique
désiré par le conseil régional c'est ça
qu'ils nous fassent y compris des études
d'impact c'est à dire y compris
a priori il y aussi en amont si vous
voulez l'idée c'est qu'on cesse par
exemple de financer à coups de dead et
de subventions des industries qui
n'entame pas leur chemin vers la
transition vers une économie décarbonée
concrètement donc pour ce faire on a
besoin voilà que des experts noah
compagne qu'il juge de nos délibérations
qu'ils rendent publiques leurs
commentaires et que ben ça impacte la
politique régionale sur la gratuité des
oui alors olivier un sujet qui revient
notamment chez les écologistes c'est
rendre les transports en commun plus un
trafic dont moins chers voire gratuits
vous y est favorable
alors les transports en commun doivent
être moins chers pour ceux qui n'ont pas
les moyens de payer en fait le vrai
sujet si vous voulez c'est dans une
région comme auvergne rhône alpin dont
je précise quand même vous la connaissez
bien mais que c'est pas comparable à
ile-de-france insistons sur la la
victoire il ya un maillage zones rurales
voilà exactement ile de france il ya un
maillage garde pour en savoir connais
pas tu fais en fonction des conditions
chez nous on veut de la gratuité pour
les moins de 25 ans les plus précaires
pourquoi parce que c'est là qu'il ya de
d'immenses besoins pour ba aller
chercher un emploi pour évidemment les
former pour pour des tas de raisons
enfin pour avoir une mobilité pour être
libérés d'un certain monde entraves et
moi mon grand regret par rapport à la
politique conduite depuis 2015 par
laurent wauquiez c'est que les
tarifications sociale dans notre région
en matière de transports comme en
matière de cantine d'ailleurs ont été
laminés et c'est ainsi d'ailleurs que le
président de la région se targuer
d'avoir fait beaucoup d'économies mais
la vérité c'est qu'il les a faites dans
la poche des plus pauvres et donc le
prix du billet a été pour les plus
précaires augmenté de deux fois et demie
depuis 2015 donc moi je veux revenir sur
ses décisions incongru je veux au
contraire qu'on aide les plus précaires
et je veux aussi qu'on ait un dispositif
qui permette aux 16-25 ans d'avoir tous
les week-end du vendredi jusqu'au lundi
le billet à un euro
pourquoi parce que c'est le moment où
les jeunes rentrent chez eux quand ils
sont voilà apprentis interne etc
un dernier mot à un tiers de la nouvelle
caserne quand vous êtes lancés dans
cette campagne vous avez dit que vous
voulez faire des régionales le
laboratoire de l'union de la gauche
c'est quand même mal parti et non il ya
trois listes de gauche aux régionales
alors moi je veux faire je continue à le
vouloir de ces régionales en effet un
laboratoire d'union de rassemblement et
honnêtement
on peut aussi regarder se dire que c'est
plutôt bien parti puisque bas dans
l'absolu j'étais tout seul au début et
aujourd'hui comme vous l'avez rappelé je
suis quand même accompagné la liste est
vraiment diverses toute la gauche y
représentait donc leurs amis écolos et
de l'essec donc oui il y aura europe
ecologie les verts d'un côté et puis où
ni celle de l'autre
mais honnêtement les mois et des mois de
discussions que nous avons eues ont
permis quand même déjà de mieux se
connaître et d'être mieux préparé le
soir du premier tour je pense à faire
alliance parce que c'est ça qui se
passera maintenant vous savez on est à
deux mois d'élections régionales il faut
quand même se parler aux citoyens savent
qu'il ya plus de discussions entre vous
il y 6 continue à y avoir des
discussions mais sur le mode de à quoi
pourrait ressembler la future
gouvernance de la région
mais je pense en effet que maintenant on
se retrouvera le soir du premier tour
mais on se retrouva dans de bonnes
conditions chemin c'est important et
vous avez quand même des sujets de
divergence si on prend l'énergie si on
prend la croissance si on prend la
vision de la république
tout ça ça divergent beaucoup c'est pour
ça mais en fait c'est précisément sur
cette question là que au fond est-ce
qu'il n'est pas non plus pertinents au
moins pour le premier tour de présenter
une offre diverses aux électeurs qui se
reconnaîtront dans celle qui leur paraît
la plus juste et la plus adaptée par
exemple typiquement moi je suis enfin
vous l'avez compris en faveur d'une
transition écologique que la région
accompagne mais en même temps je suis
pour la croissance économique jeu il
nous faut de la croissance quand j'ai
évoqué le nombre de jeunes qui vont se
retrouver et de moins jeunes qui vont se
retrouver au chômage
j'ai besoin que des entreprises voilà
puisse les embauches et j'ai besoin
concret de l'activité donc bon il ya
beaucoup de sujets sur lesquels il ya
encore des discussions entre nous je
pense qu'il faut qu'une ligne soit
tranchée au premier tour et puis ensuite
la cjue
la présidentielle la présidentielle
c'est un peu plus compliqué je pense que
la présidentielle il faut vraiment
qu'ils aient ce travail de pour avoir un
seul candidat
mais bon voilà ça auparavant balleux la
réunion organisée par yannick jadot
laquelle participaient notamment anne
hidalgo et me semble pertinente en tout
cas elle est dans le bon sens et puis je
vois surtout dans la jeune génération
vous connaissez les rencontres des deux
justices justice écologique justice
sociale les jeunes activistes nous
montre le chemin aussi il ya quelques
années vélo c'est la bonne candidate
pour rassembler les socialistes et les
écolos oui en tout cas je pense que les
mots tranchants en fait je pense que là
plutôt fait ses preuves
oui merci beaucoup merci à lever le
casem d'être venu nous voir ce médecin
on regarde la une du dauphiné consacré
justement aux élections régionales
dernier test avant 2022 merci pascal
jalabert et merci beaucoup
[Musique]